and adults have trouble staying focused
too according to shire us adults now
take more prescription drugs for ADHD
then children adults accounted for
fifty-three percent of the 63 million
u.s. prescriptions for attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder drugs last year
that is up from thirty-nine percent in
2007 there are a few reasons for this
one is that the symptoms of ADHD are
often persist into adulthood and others
that many adults are getting tested amid
a growing awareness of the condition can
be inherited and this news is benefiting
companies like Shire which makes the
blockbuster agh drug vyvanse says sales
have soared as competitors like concerts
ax and Ritalin lose patent protection I
want to bring in bloomberg's mark
crumpton on this and how shocked were
you when you saw this I read this
earlier today I found that very
disturbing because it's one of those
things where people find out afterwards
your kids have it and then they say you
know what you might want to get tested
too it's usually the other way around
exactly we got the the Shire CEO Fleming
orange scarf he was quoted in our story
a recent conference call with analysts
he said we've shifted more effort into
the adult ADHD market which is now more
than half of the overall market and has
the highest growth it is disturbing and
I think that there may be a couple of
reasons I mean you know we just outlined
a few right I'm as you say more people
are being diagnosed it's more accurate
you wonder also in this
hyper-competitive environment that we
are in in the professional world if some
people might be you know might be taking
you know you hear about this was a new
york times report might be taking these
drugs and you know sort of when they you
know when they in order to become more
high-performance essentially in order to
perform better well it is so competitive
you know we did that story I don't know
obviously there's no causal link that i
know of between remember the thing about
Goldman and the interns and about them
working out as you have people who were
staying there burning the midnight oil
that's that's
that's an understatement people are
working longer hours in this job
environment the last thing somebody
wants to be is unemployed yeah so you
have people who are working from dawn
till dusk and they're trying to get
something that's going to find any any
edge they can get absolutely not to make
light of this I would say in the news
business mark we all have a little a DD
here right i mean we are that's that's
another statement to that is an
understatement but i think a lot of high
performers you know they all joke that
you know you have to kind of be a DG in
order to be able to compete as you say
right do you know what you should be
able to juggle ten different things you
know what and to be interesting and i
don't mean to be funny but to be
interesting you talk about we all have
that we are the ego too i mean if you're
sitting up here you're basically saying
hey look at me right there you go well
we're all natural haha